mes amis henri guaino et gaulliste jean
pierre raffarin qui va parler des andes
dans un instant devant vous et libéral
il n'y a pas que ça d'ailleurs
et moi je suis centriste pourquoi
pourquoi cette évidence ne nous est pas
apparu plutôt nous sommes les
républicains quel que soit notre source
quelles que soient nos origines que l'on
vienne comme moi du sillon de marc
sangnier que l'on vienne de jean monnet
et robert schuman et de leur conception
clairvoyante de l'europe que l'on vienne
du monde qui soutenait 7,7 certaine idée
de la france du général de gaulle que
l'on ait voulu magnifier la démocratie
avec tocqueville nous sommes vous êtes
ils sont je suis républicain le
mouvement républicain populaire le parti
républicain
le rassemblement pour la république
pourquoi n'avons nous pas perçu plutôt
cette évidence
c'est dans les moments de transition et
de mouvance lorsque les sécurités se
dissolvent et que les repères
s'estompent qu'il est important de
savoir qui l'on est
d'houlouve d'où l'on vient ce que l'on
veut faire non pas pour nous mêmes mais
pour notre peuple qui a besoin de savoir
vers qui il peut se tourner nous avions
dit saint nicolas on domine à l'appel de
jacques chirac à lambersart dans ma
bonne ville de lambersart pour fonder
l'ump et l'ump le mot d'ordre c'était
rappelez-vous l'union après tant de
divisions entre le rpr et l'udf et nous
avons eu des belles victoires et nous
avons eu aussi un certain nombre
d'échecs dont beaucoup nous le devons à
nous-mêmes mais moi qui s'est passé du
cds
à force démocrate de force démocrate à
l'udf chez maurice leroy de l'udf à
l'ump
mon plus beau souvenir vous l'avez vue
sur cet écran tout à l'heure c'est le
discours de nicolas sarko
on trocadéro c'est ce souffle
cette puissance qui est allé chercher au
fond de lui-même pour vous appeler pour
nous appeler au sursaut national pour
nous expliquer que cette république
était en péril que la liberté est en
prison pendant que les délinquants
étaient en liberté que l'égalité c'était
paul le nivellement c'était l'égalité
des chances que la fraternité s'était
pas l'assistanat
c'était la capacité à donner un avenir à
nos jeunes grâce au mérite et à l'école
de la république que la laïcité s'était
pas l'intégration qui a été un échec
mais la simulation aux valeurs de la
république
ces dessins le souffle du trocadéro
alors mes amis retrouvons ce souffle
vous allez me dire en 2012 nous avons
perdu oui nous avons perdu en 2012 à
cause du cynisme de madame le pen et du
reniement de monsieur bayrou
et moi je viens vous dire ici et c'est
un appel que je lance c'est pas besoin
de convaincre mes amis lui dei qui vont
venir avec nous participe à la primaire
je le dis si le centre est partout la
circonférence nuls pas la place du
centre et d'être avec la droite pour
défendre la république et la démocratie
alors il est temps il est temps que nous
militions il est temps que nous nous
réveillons il est temps que nous
résistions que nous allions chercher ce
souffle de nicolas sakozy au trocadéro
pour rétablir cette république qui est
en péril
cette république qui est assassiné il
est temps que nous puissions être
derrière celui qui nous a redonné un
espoir aujourd'hui
depuis qu'il a démarré sa campagne à
lambersart encore chez moi merci nicolas
il est temps que nous puissions compter
sur lui tout son coeur tout son souffle
et toute cette énergie pour que nous
puissions rétablir la république en
france